Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man 3 marvel
video tom holland was posting again this time on
purpose or leaking stuff on purpose i should say
there's also a really cool andrew garfield iron
man clip going around too talking about the
avengers so i'll include that in the video too if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there's going to be a bunch
of big spider-man stuff happening in the next
couple of months including venom 2 trailers
and all kinds of other stuff too we're doing
an amazon giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what kind of big
easter eggs you want to see during spider-man 3.
i'll number these as we go along but you probably
saw this morning tom holland was posting a new
preview of a spider-man 3 from behind the scenes
not leaking this time with permission he's still
wearing the steve ditko suit from spiderman far
from home so the scene that they're filming in
this is probably from relatively early in the
movie before it gets shredded and he has to make
a new suit it should never be a question of course
they're always going to give him a new spider-man
suit in every single movie sometimes multiple
new suits usually for the purposes of selling
more toys as long as the new suits are badass
i totally don't care but the thing here is that
he's also wearing a mask on top of his mask so
to speak just to show people the conditions that
they're filming under they're filming the movie
in atlanta like they film the other spider-man
movies in atlanta they're production websites
that are still referring to the movie's title as
spider-man homesick but that title could wind up
changing by the time sony and marvel officially
have tom holland to leak it they're filming
this on a standard blue screen here just because
whatever's happening is part of an action scene
that's just way too big to film in the real world
he's crouched in a fighting pose with one of his
fists clenched that's why i say it's probably from
a fight scene with electro or one of the other
potential sinister six villains michael keaton was
talking about coming back as the vulture recently
but i don't know how big he would be during
the movie it might just wind up being a cameo
if this isn't going to be a full-blown sinister
six movie and just from all the other stuff
that we've been hearing about the movie it sounds
like it's not going to be full-blown sinister six
yet it looks like he's just crouched there on an
elevated metal walkway there's not a lot to go on
here because it's all blue screen they're going to
be creating this digitally but there is the dude
creeping behind him just out of frame everybody
was wondering about what's going on with this zoom
enhance if you blow the image out it's kind of
hard to tell but it looks like he's a white dude
with just a really really dirty hand so obviously
it couldn't be jamie foxx's electro character
he doesn't seem quite tall enough to be ned leeds
it could also just be one of the crew members
helping get the scene ready to be filmed making
sure tom holland doesn't walk off the side of the
platform that they're filming on which does happen
to actors all the time because some of them can't
see when they have their masks on robert downey
jr famously said that he couldn't see a thing
when he was filming the iron man movies this is
him joking about literally not being able to see
two feet in front of him because of the lights
blaring in his face when the helmet was up
when they when that thing clamps onto your
head yes is that thing really there or is
it not really there excellent question because
initially it was everything was really there
they wanted to spend as little as they could on
cg replacement so i remember this helmet went
on and like there'd be a shot and i'd be in this
whole suit and they say all right robert you're
going to it's like you landed on the roof so when
we say action just go like that like you just
landed and then start moving forward so i put this
helmet on and it slammed closed and i couldn't see
anything and then these led lights went on and it
was like manchurian candidate like i could i was
absolutely blinded by the time we're doing the
last avengers they just be like hey robert would
you mind putting on that helmet no yes no put two
dots here and then you can paint it in like yeah
the joke there obviously is that by the time they
got to the first avengers movies when they started
doing the add it in post style of filming iron man
scenes where he literally just walks around on set
with the dots on him and then they add the suit
in post-production with a few exceptions you have
scenes like this spider-man iron man scene where
they need some reference so they haven't wear sort
of that vest that's the iron man chest piece but
that's it that's all he has to wear they did the
exact same thing for benedict cumberbatch when
he was going to wear his version of the iron man
suit they were just going to tune it so that it
would have the aya bhagamoto in the center instead
of the arc reactor that was a really cool deleted
scene so hopefully we'll see them add that back in
for doctor strange 2 or do a version of it because
they're getting so crazy with the multiverse
speaking of which marvel is filming both
spider-man 3 and doctor strange 2 at the same
time right now benedict cumberbatch we all know
is going to be a major character in spider-man 3.
he's like the big avengers crossover character
replacing iron man as a mentor to spider-man
but here's the thing with that though they're
actually filming spider-man 3 in atlanta like i
said but doctor strange 2 is getting ready to film
in the uk so i'm assuming that means that doctor
strange won't be around for all of spider-man 3.
he'll just show up in some key parts of the movie
probably a pretty similar situation to what we
saw of iron man during spider-man homecoming
some pep talks a few assists an action scene
and then some sort of post-credit scene or an
ending tag scene that's meant to be a doctor
strange 2 teaser because now doctor strange 2
is being released after spider-man 3. in fact it's
the next marvel movie right after they've released
spider-man 3 so of course they're probably going
to be connected they did a version of that with
thor in the doctor strange post-credits scene
but that was more of like a whole scene that they
just clipped out of thor ragnarok in fact taika
watiti is the one that shot that doctor strange
post-credit scene even though scott derrickson was
the one that was shooting the doctor strange movie
this is them just practicing more of the stunts i
can't wait to see him leak the new version of the
suit totally on purpose of course now the leaks
pretty much happen on sony's clock like they tell
tom holland we want the whole world to know about
this so please just post it accidentally quote
unquote on your instagram there's still all kinds
of multiverse spider-burst theories about what's
going on with electro's character and easter eggs
for other live-action versions of spider-man this
clip is of andrew garfield talking about
crossing over with the avengers characters
listen to what he thinks about his version of
spider-man meeting iron man especially since
we've had so many movies with tom holland being
so close to the mcu version of iron man um you
know i i was trying to team him up team him up
with every different avenger and he wouldn't get
along with tony stark because i don't think he
he likes he's arrogant too arrogant ethics are
dubious um and uh you know peter's a man of the
people peter's the working class hero whereas
tony's this rich gazillionaire that you know is
arguably you know not all that responsible or
kind of heartfelt the interesting thing about that
clip you have to remember is that one he's talking
about his version of spider-man from the amazing
spider-man movies and two this clip is from 2014
a couple years ago so at that point we'd only
had iron man 3 in the first avengers movies so
iron man hadn't snapped the infinity gauntlet and
sacrificed himself to save the entire universe yet
but even then when he's talking about robert
downey jr's iron man i don't know maybe he
just hadn't seen all the iron man movies up
to that point but i felt like he had a pretty
decent character arc so far and he wasn't
quite as self-serving as andrew garfield is
making him sound like but some of what he
says is factually correct like spider-man
has been traditionally a blue-collar hero a man
of the people a true man of the people iron man
has always been this billionaire industrialist so
far removed from street level so to speak usually
one of the tropes of spider-man movies in all the
spider-man movies even the toby maguire spider-man
movies is that spider-man is pretty much broke
all the time but i do like the idea that once
they eventually get to full-blown live-action
spider-man into the spider-verse movies someday
when different versions of spider-man interact
with the other avengers characters they'll have
very different dynamics with each of them so the
people that tom holland spider-man is really close
to on the avengers might not get along with andrew
garfield or toby maguire's versions of spider-man
and just using iron man as an example part of
the fun of that too is finding out what the
backstory is there what kind of person is their
version of iron man from their home world what
are the avengers from their worlds like that whole
what if scenario is basically what they're doing
with marvel's what if disney plus series i think
based on the winter soldier's costume here for
example the marvel zombies episode in particular
is going to be a big avengers episode like what
if avengers infinity war as far as i know they're
not going to be doing any big spider verse stuff
during the what if series but there's always
potential for that because it's an animated series
if they don't have any of the budget limitations
that the live-action movies have they can write
whatever kind of action scenes they want they
could put as many versions of spider-man in an
episode that they want to and the really cool
thing about the rights issue with sony is that
marvel actually does produce most of the half-hour
animated spider-man series not sony because they
have the rights to do those i believe it's sony
that has the rights to do live-action hour-long
television shows marvel and disney have the rights
to half-hour animation and that's basically what
we're getting with the what-if episodes the sony
people were teasing that we were going to see some
sort of spider-man 3 trailer before the end of the
year i don't know what that's going to look like
what kind of teaser it's going to be but they said
that they would show us something before the end
of the year and we'll also probably see a venom 2
trailer as well the venom 2 movie is pretty much
done they're finishing editing and post-production
now so they're just working on special effects
they could release a teaser trailer anytime they
want but everyone let me know in the comments
which other avengers characters would you want
to see andrew garfield's spider-man team up with
in the mcu if he ever gets a cameo scene speaking
of giant spiders everyone click here for my full
mandalorian season 2 episode 2 video and click
here to watch tom holland talk about spider-man 3.
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!